[Music]
today we're gonna talk about what I say
look I know is technically a four-letter
word but how are we ever gonna get out
of if we can't even say the word debt
haha
among the subjects that people like to
talk about debt ranks right between
toenail fungus and other people's dreams
your brain just doesn't want to hear it
and that emotional reaction is partly
why it's so hard to pay it off but
there's hope
researchers have figured out a way to
rewire your brain into taking this
monster head-on not only can it save
your finances it can teach you a lot
about how your brain works
and maybe in the future you won't have
to be afraid of the word
[Music]
the average debt holder in America
currently holds about $8,000 in credit
card debt
over three cards 26,000 students and
another 10,000 in car loans that's a lot
for one person to manage and they all
have different interest rates terms and
loan balances in short it's a bit of a
confusing mess so how do we get started
first things first
you've got to mind the gap the gap is
the difference between what you make and
spend in a month without a gap there's
no money available to make any kind of
progress the two ways to widen your gap
are more income or less spending
hopefully it's a mixture of both once
you have a gap to work with it's time to
think of strategy if you ask a
mathematician how to structure your debt
they'd probably recommend something like
the Avalanche approach you list your
debts by interest rates with the highest
at the top and the lowest at the bottom
you pay minimums on everything except
the loan with the highest interest rate
which gets the biggest part of your gap
once that one's paid off you use the
increased cash flow to move down the
hillside like an avalanche by the time
you get to the bottom you save the most
money because you paid as little
interest as possible
it's mathematical it's logical and it
doesn't work very well
the Avalanche approach may be
mathematically sound but it omits one
important factor your brain humans
aren't robots or Vulcans they're
emotional beings they get discouraged
they get overwhelmed they have trouble
staying on course it's the same reason
why those debt consolidation plans can
be a bad idea it may seem like you're
simplifying your life to put all of your
loans into one big basket but what it
really does is create a giant
being dead monster that feels so
intimidating your brain just gives up so
is there a method that works with your
brain psychology instead of against it
well it turns out Julia were in the
middle of something here I know I was
about to put it down but then I cleared
a boss stage and upgraded the frosting
on my cupcake cannon I think I can get
to the persimmon palace by bedtime turns
out the same mind-control techniques
found in video games can work with your
finances game designers strategically
dole out positive reinforcements
clearing a board of gems upgrading your
loot which floods your brain with
pleasurable dopamine and keeps you
playing at first these rewards are
handed out easily and often to get you
hooked and then more spaced out and
difficult as time goes by it's really
effective and a little bit evil but the
same brain hacking technique can be used
to pay off your debt
it's called the snowball method instead
of listing your dentist by interest rate
we list them by balance like the
Avalanche approach you pay minimums on
all of them except you focus your
firepower on the smallest balance once
that's wiped out you roll the extra cash
down the hill to the next highest
balance and so on and so on the snowball
method ensures you easy victories early
on to keep you motivated every time you
cross a debt off your list
it's like slaying a beast and upgrading
your weapon if your brain will keep
chasing that dopamine fix even as the
levels get more challenging
while someone using the snowball method
will technically pay more overall
interest than someone using the
Avalanche approach that assumes that
they're both going to see it through but
a study by Northwestern University found
that snow ballers were much more likely
to actually stick with the plan and
successfully eliminate their debt even
if they owed more money than the
Avalanche errs because they gave
themselves that dopamine it
gulia
no matter what method you use the
hardest part of getting out of debt is
often just starting and it can get
lonely because you know people don't
like to talk about it but with
determination and planning you can turn
debt into something you don't want to
think about into something you don't
have to and that's our two cents
you